[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a casa mia come
potete vedere c'è un pochettino di
casino perché stiamo preparando una
festa
just dance a tema halloween se volete
venite con me una festa a tema ragazzi
l'importante addobbare il tutto il
meglio possibile grazie caro perché gli
addobbi sono l'anima
quindi ragazzi oggi diamo inizio a la
ricetta culinaria preferita di farli j
la preparazione della zucca cosa vuol
dire tutto questo che evitiamo devo qua
la zucca sopra il cielo mi dà il
telefono un attimo giampiero ti senti mi
serve un aiuto con la zucca ma sai fare
tu la zucca si tumi monti video non
importa mi servono aiuto per la zucca
che non riesco a farla corradi per
grazie grazie
[Musica]
ragazzi questa è la casa terminata
perché credo che più di così non si
possa fare ci sono anche i ragnetti sul
muro però venite con me perché just
dance che conosce le mie passioni e non
so neanche come sia possibile mi ha
inviato questa cosa qua che io però non
so più cosa effettivamente ragazzi ma
sarà il costume per la mia festa è un
vestito rosso ai michael jackson ma dai
ma ora venderete tratto un bisturi
michael jackson che gli ha detto quando
comunque vero è la mia passione michael
jackson mi vesto come michael jackson in
thriller
[Musica]
dottore oggi giovane e adesso introdotto
ragazzi ricchi e poveri ragazzi direi
che siamo a posto io ci sono e niente
aspettiamo i vostri
[Risate]
[Musica]
stanotte
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
in finale
ricordati di ballare prima di me
[Musica]
libero
ragazzi ma chi è seguitemi
[Musica]
ma la vuoi finire ma cos'è ma perché
certi ma perché si fa miracoli è per
caso la festa grazie
[Musica]
si è divertito una cifra era ormai anche
per me però siamo stanchi ma te la fai
un'altra partita sì dopo questa però va
[Applauso]
[Musica]
è suo
all'orecchio
lì
c'è un po di video in questo qui
domani
shan xi ieri ho diciassette ogni festa
che si rispetti c'è anche ovviamente la
torta che taglierò io ringrazio just
dance per aver organizzato questa festa
bellissima in descrizione trovato un
link per partecipare un contest e
partecipare appunto la festa finale e il
prossimo video maglia ad ora io taglio
non o in quello del come si tagliano le
torte spettro mi sono posto non solo
questo basta mangiate guai
[Musica]